110 milliards d'euros c'est ce que
représente la commande publique en
France
110 milliards d'euros c'est un des
leviers opérationnels que nous vous
proposons d'actionner pour verdir notre
économie
à la fin de la précédente législature le
Parlement a adopté la loi climat et
résilients majeures dans notre droit de
la commande publique et dans le
renforcement de sa dimension écologique
nous sommes aujourd'hui quasiment à
mi-chemin de l'entrée en vigueur de sa
disposition la plus ambitieuse
comme prévu par l'article 35 de la Loi
climat et résilience d'ici l'été 2026
100% des marchés publics intégreront un
critère environnemental
d'ici à cet échéance il nous reste
encore du travail à accomplir pour que
les marchés publics puissent constituer
un levier massif et incontournable en
faveur de la transition écologique
c'est tout le sens du titre 2 que je
vous présente qui est consacré aux
enjeux environnementaux de la commande
publique
l'article 12 habilite le gouvernement à
introduire par ordonnance un nouveau
motif d'exclusion de la commande
publique en cas de non-respect de
l'obligation d'établir un rapport de
durabilité
cette obligation est prévue par la
directive relative à la publication
d'information en matière de durabilité
par les entreprises dites directives
CSRD
il s'agit là d'un dispositif analogue à
celui qui avait été introduit par la loi
climat-résilience à propos du plan de
vigilance des sociétés
l'article 13 qui occupera à juste titre
une place prédominante dans nos débats
comprend trois mesures principales
tout d'abord il poursuit le renforcement
d'espaceurs de promotion des achats
publics socialement et écologiquement
responsables dont l'importance est
primordial pour orienter l'évolution de
la commande publique ensuite il crée un
nouveau motif d'exclusion des marchés
publics pour le non respect de
l'obligation d'établir un BGS bilan des
missions de gaz à effet de serre enfin
il précise la façon dont l'offre
économiquement la plus avantageuse et
déterminée notamment par la prise en
compte du critère environnemental cela
dans l'attente de l'entrée en vigueur de
l'article 35 de la Loi climère
résilience qui pourra être anticipée
pour certains marchés
l'article 14 enfin étant les
dispositions de ce même article et du
présent projet de loi dans les
collectivités d'outre-mer et en
Nouvelle-Calédonie
la discussion des séries s'est avéré
fructueuse je relève l'adoption le 3
dispositions additionnelles à
l'initiative du gouvernement
correspondant articles 12 bis 12 terres
et 12 quatters ces derniers introduisent
des exceptions au droit de la commande
publique dans des cas très spécifiques à
savoir les activités d'opérateur de
réseau il s'agit de prévenir les risques
d'infructuosité des marchés dans un
contexte économique marqué par la rareté
de l'offre par rapport à des besoins
croissants
nous ne sommes pas ici dans le cas des
marchés publics classiques auxquels
accède et doivent continuer d'accéder
nos entreprises locales le Sénat
également introduit un article 13 bisant
à favoriser le rétrophyte dans le
renouvellement annuel des flottes de
véhicules des acheteurs publics la
discussion du projet de loi en
commission s'est avéré elle aussi très
utile nous avons tout d'abord enrichi en
plusieurs points le contenu de l'espace
vert afin de mieux les orienter vers la
prise en compte des critères
environnementaux j'ai également fait
adopter quatre amendements pour
renforcer l'obligation d'établir un BGS
aujourd'hui trop peu appliqué
ces amendements permettent d'utiliser
des leviers incitatifs et contraignants
tout en développant le recours du BG
simplifié
enfin à l'article 13 bis relatif au
rétrophyte il m'a paru préférable de
préciser que les véhicules rétrophités
des pris en compte dans les véhicules à
faible et à très faible émission plutôt
que d'imposer un seuil minimal de
recours à ce type de véhicule c'est ce
que souhaitait le Sénat de manière
prématurée et surtout inadaptée à
certaines flottes de véhicules publics
je suis convaincue que le texte y a été
adopté en commission soumis à notre
assemblée aujourd'hui est ambitieux il
est le juste équilibre entre les
avancées nécessaires à la transition
écologique et la capacité des acheteurs
publics et des entreprises à absorber de
nouvelles contraintes de fait je ne
doute pas
tout comme en commission que nos
discussions cette semaine seront
constructives seront constructives et
qu'elles permettront de tendre vers un
seul objectif le verdissement de la
commande publique je vous